[Music]
information age it's designed to look at
the role of information of mechanical
engineering now my background is in
physics when I came to I didn't know
anything about mechanical engineering I
knew a bit about information and over
the past five years I've been amazed at
the extent that which problems and
information and information processing
permeate the whole fabric of mechanical
engineering where you buy car it's got
30 micro processors event right that's a
lot of microprocessors they all have to
talk to each other in the right way or
else you're cognizant properly similarly
I become a had a great appreciation as I
might up I try to build extremely small
to powerful computers and I've I've got
a much greater appreciation for the
extent which Mechanical Engineering has
contributed to the information
revolution many of the primary
breakthroughs that allow us to have the
computer revolution at all were
mechanical breakthroughs breakthroughs
materials great 3d and processing and
Rangers in manufacturing so this
conference is here a recognition of this
fact and discuss what's happened and
what we're going to do about it
my name is Seth Lloyd I'd like to her I
am a member of a triumvirate that
professionals to set up a three-man
group while other organizers are Sonny
sue and Sanjay Sarma I should say that
the corrector it was an ancient Roman
custom and Sonic's armor is the julius
caesar of our tribe
he is the one who really did all the
organisation for this Sonny and I are
just like the pumping of the Crassus
okay so to keep us on schedule I'd like
to introduce our first speaker
Natsu the head of the department of
mechanical engineering he's the cross
professor of mechanical engineering at
MIT can you hear me if I talk from here
I guess well certainly I'd like to
welcome all of you to MIT and I'd like
to thank our colleagues for organizing
this says the Lord said he didn't know
anything about mechanical engineering at
the time we interviewed him for a job
that's not what he said we hire them
because he thought he told us he knew a
lot about McCaig and certainly it has
been pleasure to work with my colleagues
in information area today you will be
hearing from very distinguished speakers
and especially the keynote speakers
today and the luncheon speaker dinner
speaker these three people although they
may not realize it they had a profound
influence the way we developed
information technology in fact they had
a profound influence on me
the way I think about information and
indeed many of the things we have done
have been affected by their thinking in
directory and directory so I am looking
forward to their talk today and I hope
you enjoy the presentation as well mayor
next slide
one of the reasons we decided that the
price we should have this conference is
that we should exchange information as
to what all of our sister institutions
are doing in the field of information
technology and also we want to tell you
about what we are doing and also I speak
no big secret as to what we have in mind
I hope that some of our sis institutions
that do not have strong programs in
information area will start programs and
hire our PhDs we have produced a lot of
PhDs and hopefully you hire them and
that in turn will make room for our
future students in our programs and so
forth and I guess one of the important
issues is yit in mechanical engineering
in fact within our own department we
have had a great deal of debate on this
issue
in fact the first committee we formed in
our department to look at this issue
came back with a report that says we
shouldn't do anything in this field so
we formed another committee headed by
Harry Assad on that committee came back
yet said yes we should do something so
so we said gee now we have unanimous
support for the idea so this is how we
justified getting into this business and
so so since then we did a number of
different things I want to review with
you briefly what it is that we are
trying to do it all has to do with our
educational goal here in mechanical
engineering and I'm sure is true of many
other departments at MIT our job is to
produce future leaders so we ask
ourselves what our future leaders need
to know to be lead industry in to be a
leader in engineering academia and so
and so forth so that our conclusion was
that indeed for future leaders it is
almost indispensable not to teach us
something about information technology
we have to
the background information knowledge
required so that they could become
leaders very few things are purely
mechanical anymore and indeed the whole
idea that the mechanical things consist
of geometry I think is ancient and we
have to depart from that and so we
decided to go into this so what we have
decided to do is in addition to is not
in in lieu of or in Placer but in
addition to the traditional mechanical
engineering subjects we have to teach
our students something about information
technology and also biology so so we
decided that one of the major goals of a
me department is to transform some of my
colleagues think that this use of the
world the word transform is too strong a
word but really to transform in my
opinion to transform mechanical
engineering from a discipline that has
been based primarily on physics into one
that's based on physics information
biology while maintaining strong
foundation in design if you look at this
you can see that the word physics and
biology are related to natural phenomena
but word like information is really
really related to synthesis or
artificial science or how it related it
turns out that that's what engineering
is all about in some ways because we do
design and design really is artificial
science or synthesis so in 1995 we
create double of laboratory for
information Science and Technology under
the leadership of Harry asada as
directed and Ian Hunter is a co-director
of the laboratory so they are the ones
who worked very hard to create a
research base create educational
programs so all the credit goes to those
people plus other colleagues who are in
the double of lab so what we have done
is we added very outstanding faculty
members and many of these colleagues
have disciplinary backgrounds other than
mechanical engineering self loiters
physicist
Sonia sue is a luxury engineer and
you'll hear about what they are doing
and Sanjay sama is is mechanical
engineer so you can see that the new
intellectual frontiers these people are
creating by working together is really
what's making information technology
possible within the department
mechanical engineering at MIT so you'll
hear about new subjects they are
creating and they have a vigorous
research programs and so forth one of
the things that I thought I should that
tell you a little bit about our
philosophy about research and I keep
talking about this with anyone I can
talk to is that if you plot in a
horizontal axis research a spectrum and
then along this axis if you plot impacts
how to submit the research activity
level this is hard to see it slides not
very good so this is a research spectrum
so this is we go from very basic
research or fundamental research you can
define any way you like and this is
technology innovation and this is
activity level along this axis and
typical distribution is something like
that most of the professors and large
number of researchers are in this mid
middle area they spend at the 90% of our
College set in universities are in this
area but if you look at the impact made
by this kind of research the curve is
just inverse so I say at MIT we should
concentrate at this end and at that end
of the research spectrum and I say we
shouldn't really care whether someone is
at this end what they at the end rather
than argue about what is engineering
science and so and so forth there are
all sorts of basic research one can do
and there's all kind technology
innovation one can do some people are
able to do both
some people in the state at this end or
the other end and I said that's fine and
then let the middle ground be love to
someone else so I guess one of the
things we need to talk about what is
information information can be defined
in many different ways you know to
prepare your slides I looked up
Webster's dictionary and there's some
many many definitions right so for the
purpose of what I'm going to say in a
few minutes
I say informations and knowledge that
must be added to achieve certain
functional requirements so information
can be measured in terms of probability
of success in terms of achieving those
functional requirements then what is
information technology if that's
information what is information
technology that we are concerned about
here it has to do with generation of
information storage of information
transmission of information card
application codification should be done
there some high-tech world up there
algorithms comprehension of information
deciphering information you transmit
machines that produce information
devices that deal with information and
equipment for doing the all of the world
ok so that's information technology very
broad one of the issues some of our
colleagues raised within our own
Department when we talked about this
what is information there is no such
thing as information but to me all of
these are included within the term
information technology or IT measure
next
I know two reasons why mechanical
engineers must get involved with
information technology and this again is
influenced greater by my association
with partly the torsion Neil Pappalardo
and Alex double of you'll be hearing
from from the later on mechanical things
are getting much much smaller I didn't
realize how small they are getting until
I joined Popkin in the area of
lithography and it's really amazing
literally in the cross section of our
hair we can put in thousand lines and
that's a lot of electric circuits on a
cross section of our hair and we can do
this because of mechanical engineering
technology because of optics and because
of all these things and as a result of
this we started looking for optics
people and I think today if I may say so
our department has a strongest artists
parts group within MIT if
in the country as a whole NASA next
slide the other thing that's happening
is that the opposite end of the spectrum
mechanical engineering is becoming very
highly distributed factories are located
all over design is done globally you
have to exchange information in large
number of people in distant places got
to work together to create the same
final output and that cannot be done
without our understanding of networking
without an understanding of how design
should be done in a systematic fashion
and so forth
it turns out that mechanical engineers
are always dealt with information we
never called it information we are where
we are always in the area of design and
manufacturing is actually these two
fields menu plate information to create
artifacts and that's the business we
have been in and we just do not call
them information so I'll give you a
short very simple example
how we evolved in my own research we
evolved asking some very basic questions
how one goes about designing simple
things to large complex systems and how
it resulted in a complete new technology
for creating software as well as many
other things so it turns out an XML is 9
there are only two axioms one is called
independency axioms the other one is
called information axiom and it requires
that the functional requirements must be
independent throughout the design
process and we have to design define
what we mean a functional requirements
and so forth but he's actually that's
one of the accident the other axiom says
information content must be minimized
during the entire design process very
simple statement and from these we have
large number of theorems correlates what
have you which can be used by students
in in coming out of the design so based
on this kind of thinking we create that
we in fact create a very complicated
commercial software and I like to just
tell you a little bit about the process
by which one goes about creating this
kind of software nation
so in XML sine we talk about going from
mapping from domain to domain first of
all we just assume that there are four
domains customer took to my functional
domain physical domain process domain
and then as a next step we say we are
you have to map it between the domains
when you map between the domains you
have to maintain independence of
function requirements and that is you
have to maintain the from what it is
that you are trying to achieve to be
independent from other things that you
are not achieve and then after that you
have to zigzag and create a hierarchy
and you cannot decompose something in by
staying in one of the domains you have
to zigzag so that the only way you can
decompose is exactly and then you can
create hierarchical structure in each
domain and then in dependency axiom
tells you which are the good designs
which are the bad designs and then it
tells you a procedure by which you have
to follow your design to be able to
assess what is in axioms so if prying
this idea to a software it looks like
this applying this software this sort of
like a V model we are going from
functional domain to design domain and
that's at this part of the leg going
from design domain to process domain is
it this part of the flag in software
design and essentially we design along
the select first and then this is in
typically it's very coolant to
object-oriented programming but by doing
this we create object-oriented program
the structure with without any human
intervention so in fact you can think of
creative software without much human
intervention measured next so as a
result of this kind of thinking as you
design it as it is design it you have a
matrix this sorry that you cannot see
this but these are functional
requirements and this could be the
design parameters in this case we are
showing design parameters versus process
variables but you can plot the same
thing where this is function requirement
and there's
the design parameters these are what
people might call object object oriented
programming to see what you call object
that is a data and this is a method so
in terms of an object or in the
programming language that's the way it's
gonna be
so result of this without spending too
much time result of this you get
something like this this is like an
electric circuit diagram each one of
these little boxes the modules at the
lowest level the module we define is
very specific
the model we define is a role of the
design matrix the result of that is you
get a diagram like this if we call flow
diagram just like electric circuit
diagram okay just like a capacitor
resistor we have these modules it turns
out that this is generated automatically
once you do XML design with a click or
button you get this whole thing then the
only thing the programmer does is
sticking modules in fact programmer food
works on this module it's all as very
simple modules because this is a roll
roll of design matrix this person can be
located in India this first can be in
Boston and so on so forth and all you
have to do is stick them in there just
like that you pop in resistors or
capacitors and then you have a software
I teach this too right now I teach
graduate students in our in my XML
design class and it turns out that one
of the student is a PhD from MIT who
work for Xerox for about 15 years he
came back for master's degree called
systems design and management program
and I have another student who has also
equally long experience software design
at Xerox and they tell me that the way
we did this took only 20% or less of the
time it normally takes as zeros the
software we developed a nor the software
very well did they play with it and then
they work with people who are doing this
and in the case of hardware design
machine design I was talking to
president of SVG DL a real high tower he
says now we can he really thinks we can
cut down the time it takes to develop
new machines
by fact of two why do you used to take
30-some months can do it in 18 months or
so so systemic thinking having a very
rigorous criterion for good design
enabled us to do this the purpose of
talking about this is the fact that not
only I want to tell you a little bit
about my own work but the fact that we
started out with a very basic research
asking the very simple question of what
constitutes good design and then having
done all of that now we can apply to
software design this is a technology
innovation software design hardware
design or what have you so I think the
mechanical engineering departments must
weave all of the these information
technology in teaching our students
otherwise I don't really think they can
become leaders we done having background
information at technology area I don't
think our mechanical engineering
students can ever become leaders they
can continue to do traditional
mechanical engineers work but if our
goal is to produce people who can become
leaders they have to have understanding
in this very important area and having
done some of these kind of work and
having seen what my colleagues I have
amazing colleagues as really it's a
understatement in many ways many of
colleagues as used here today and
tomorrow are really doing very very
amazing things and I'm convinced that
the kind of things that we can do in
mechanical engineering will contribute
to the future of information era and
that's with that I guess I'll stop and
that keeps
Excel right on time okay thanks very
much
actually we have time for a question or
two yes well you're saying that MIT is
taking a lead an IT or I didn't say that
I said we're doing a lot in it but well
I said what I meant to say is that this
conference is is in some sense going to
influence other mechanical engineering
departments throughout the country
perhaps where they might be an offshoot
there back then you mentioned for
example optics as an area and that's not
really something that all any
departments take us as an area do you
see that as developing future do you
think that that's is that typically
gonna happen physics departments or
engineering physics department wallace
gave up optics tree because that's not
how you get nobel prize right so you get
out of that and and until they we start
looking into information technology area
we really didn't think your optics was
that in poland for us we hire somebody
on a part-time basis to teach the optics
but there was half-hearted but they sort
of attempt to offer something but then
it's very clear once you get into
information technology area you cannot
deal with small things you cannot deal
with information transmission
communication measurement all those
things without optics technology when
you try to deal with the atomic level
tolerances there's no other way and so I
think it's very important topic in fact
I'm very pleased that we are so strong
in optics area it's amazing what they
can do
you mentioned above LEP classism related
to IT team to be grievable
yeah that's a long answer to that and
hairy asada I guess we may talk about
this there are a couple of things one is
that we created undergraduate the
elective subject undergraduate graduate
level sets s Floyd's teaching in the
area of information was of the
probability was so title yeah and then
we have in the creating a process of
creating but Harry asada calls gateway
subjects so our students can take
certain set of first level graduate
subjects and then then they can move
right into advanced graduate subjects in
electron Jeannine computer science
without having to take all the other
prerequisites so we are trying to
convince our colleagues in electro
engineering that our PhD students in
mechanical engineering ought to be able
to get a master's degree in electronic
as well while they're working on PhD but
we are still in the discussion stage so
there are lots of those things are
happening and and the fact that we are
emphasizing information means that lots
of other subjects we teach will bring
some of these things in design subjects
and other subjects we teach them about
what we mean by information and so on so
supports independent subjects as well as
incorporating some of these ideas into
existing subjects some of them might be
probably
our next speaker is popular Tuscan he is
the CEO and chairman of the board
Silicon Valley group he is we're very
lucky to have him here because he blew
up yesterday to come here he's flying
back to California this afternoon and
he's flying back here on Sunday the
semiconductor industry he's the only
person of the last five years who's made
the life of an MIT professor sound calm
so more than anybody responsible for
bringing mechanical engineering
techniques into making the information
revolution happen that was asked
professor sue but how do you get
mechanical engineering how what do you
teach here to really make relevant what
courses you take out that what is there
I'm sure that a lot of you over here can
spend a week discussing that because
it's very very important and very
relevant can can you hear me if I stand
back here can you hear me
I just wonder how sensitivity can you
hear me now yes thank you
okay let me just I'm a mechanical
engineer by training and to repeat what
Professor sue said that the optics that
I learned here was freshman physics
course was that first two weeks in a
freshman physics course and a book was
by professors Sears which was written in
the 50s so that gives you an idea how
old I am and frankly it's still relevant
so the message is what what the
professor's what good universities
Berkeley MIT Stanford all the good
universities in the country what you
have to teach is some very very basic
basic fundamentals and then teach people
how to learn and adapt themselves to the
changing environment if you do two
things just teach fundamentals
and teach people how to learn which I
think MIT and Berkeley and others to do
very well and didn't and that's what you
really have to do because the rest of
the time you don't know what's gonna
happen when I came to school here when I
was in high school somebody when I fill
the application at MIT they said what do
you want to learn and I just said
mechanical engineering somebody said why
because I like cars and that was the
reason I chose mechanical engineer I had
to put something in there because they
said what course you want to go and then
I came here and when I came here believe
it or not the they were not teaching
anything about cars
the professor hasha Schwartz was a
emeritus professor but they weren't
teaching courses in cars for ten years
what they were teaching is jet engines
because that was the arrow and so yeah
you have to always adapt another thing I
would impart to you is that in physics
or mechanical engineering or whatever
you teach you know what I always say
that you really have to teach the basic
things with the freshman and sophomore
and then Judit and senior you amplify a
little bit and you spend seven eight
years getting a PhD all you do is learn
that F equals MA but when you get a PhD
you learn that F equals MA
most of the time until you reach the
realm of quantum mechanics and I really
that's all you do
you don't really and that's what you
apply in business when I first left here
I was hired by Hill at Packard
hewlett-packard at that time was
primarily run by electrical engineers
Bill Hewlett and Dave Packard are
electrical engineers and by the way Bill
Hewlett is a graduate of MIT and I know
that a lot of people think yes I
associate them with Stanford because
they basically have given more money to
Stanford and Stanford
but but they are really a bill is a
graduate of my team and at that time I
was the only mechanical engineer that
was higher professionally and the
electronics industry at that time was
moving from big boxes with tubes
into transistors and I'm sure some of
you realize when you go from a big box
with transistors lots of heat and go
transistors small boxes miniaturized the
biggest problem in those days the
transistors with germanium and silicon
the very very sensitive to temperature
you know if you went over 150 degrees
centigrade in fact if you went much over
120 degrees centigrade a lot of these
circuits do not work at all
so biggest problem who was making
circuits work so they asked me about it
and I used some very simple principles
of mechanical engineering frankly a lot
of estimates and in and I just came up
with some formulas which I said what you
have to use and they took this little
document and made a little manual about
if you have a box this big you can put
so much power into it and some basic
principles how you can cool power
transistors as you know I did simple
things like you know put grease under
the transistors which made the cons
actual conduction better and put a
little mass at the bottom of put a
little heat dissipator and they thought
I was a magician you know the point is I
showed them that I bred a formula that
temperature is voltage and the heat
transfer is current and resistance is 1
over K and L better I was magician you
know industry that echo circuits the
point is the basic principles that what
you learn is really what you really
apply in life we only share with you
some of the thoughts and what we do here
at Silicon Valley and how mechanical
engineering is really very very relevant
the information age next slide please
well I want to spend some time here and
I also want to say very little about
bioengineering as you know when I was
going to school here professor Mann was
here he was working with University of
maternal working on prosthetics and
limbs and things like that at that time
we always think of today mechanical
engineering is so essential in medicine
in because we measure temperature
pressure flow and nowaday before doctors
always guessed that things you know they
kind of that's what they call practice
medicine because they really practice on
us but today you can actually measure
things if we can actually give them
temperature pressure we can give them a
you mind out a lot of this information
is very very relevant to what's going on
in your body
next type trees now this is by the way
you don't have to take any notes all you
have to do is give your email address to
Professor sunny or Lloyd or and then we
will email love this is that all on a
computer we can email them to you or we
can make copies of the overheads so in
the old days as you know we we really
had years of mechanical engineering and
what we call the multiplier for the
Brawn a mechanical man Engineers
basically made leverage give leverage so
the human beings can lift large weights
and nowadays of course Mechanical
Engineering is empowering what we call
the brain next one please
as Professor Lord said mechanical
engineering is at the core of that
information technology today you cannot
make semiconductors without mechanical
engineering frankly I'm not going to be
that selfish there are some chemical
engineering and there's some material
science and there are some other
disciplines but fundamentally to get
down to the small geometries and to
really really measure a lot of these
things the mechanical engineering at the
heart of it and our company frankly I
will say this you cannot make Pentiums
which is since 1994
every Pentium most of the Pentiums built
are built on our machine and every
generation or Pentium sets that is
advanced from
when 120 megahertz up to 1 gigahertz now
the only way you can get that is to make
the lines thinner I put more transistors
on it and we at SVG are the enabler for
that basic technology that was developed
and I'll show you how that works so we
are extremely important for the whole
internet and information technology next
slide please
for those of you who have that for the
semiconductor industry basically you
know you take a big in get that in fact
I have seen at MIT a big place where
they used used to grow ingots here and
they gave it to IBM you take the ingot
you saw it first mechanical engine
problem then you take you basically put
photoresist you spray photoresist on it
which is not a mechanical engineering
problem how do you spray something
that's kind of viscous smoothly
you gotta get accuracies of plus or
minus 20 angstroms that's what you have
to really do on this so only one only
one micron thickness so what we used to
do in the old days we used to really
charge a huge capacitor and suddenly
charge put it on the motor and the motor
really expand it very fast so that it
can really get acceleration very fast so
that you can really get a good flow then
of course after that you have project
the image which is not a mechanical
engineering what we make you have to
project the real tiny transistors and
all the edges to be 5 microns now is
0.18 micron is a technology today in
production and then you develop it then
of course then you etch it you put some
other stuff in it there's another
mechanical engine you can make furnaces
where we basically it's a it's a heater
and you basically put some gases in it
and you have to make sure that there are
no stagnate stagnant flow you have to
really flow it properly another
mechanical engineering chronometer so
really make sure that you don't have any
particles may have smooth flow
another area of mechanical engineering
so I don't think mechanical engineering
goes into all of it next one please
lithography of course is basically the
most difficult and the most important
part of the making SEM semiconductors
that's the ability to put the finest
image on the
and if you can't do that whether you H
it whatever you H whatever you develop
whatever you do is is nothing that's too
but that's what that's the basic enabler
that gets to a thinner and thinner lines
and believe it or not
optics fundamental geometric optics
that's taught in two weeks or three
weeks that's all we use year after year
for the last thirty years so you know
whatever you learn in two weeks maybe
less maybe you should amplify it a
little bit some applications so that
people can get better at it and like
professor sue said the physics
department you know I think that's very
elementary but you know when you really
start using it really making machines
with it you find out that it's not that
elementary things get very very
difficult and next one please
this is a sketch of a typical machine
you know it is amazing sometimes that
the damn thing works at all frankly it's
just so accurate and so precise too just
to give an idea we we actually do print
point one micron and the accuracies are
between 0.01 microns so you have to make
machines that measure 21 microns because
you cannot buy these things and these
machines these disk carriages these
carriages have to accelerate just to
give an idea these things run about 100
wafers per hour so it's about one and a
half wafers per minute so in 60 seconds
we have to take away for put it in take
it out put it in and then step put about
50 or so step basically dies on it take
it out all accurately and you have to do
this so these are very very fast and
very accurate everybody can do things
slowly and you know but many you start
you basically have to hit a machine and
then you stop the vibration
I used to make disk drives before that
youlet Packard but this drives compared
to this we stores argue about you know
how fast you can accelerate something
and stop it we find out that when you
accelerate something that's ok you can
get there but then it's PI blades so how
do you stop the vibration before you can
start reading or printing and I think
most people realize that in this drives
the the settling time sometimes is much
longer than the access time and I think
in this case is that we have to bring it
in align it accurately which is wafer to
wafer layer to layer you have to do 26
layers on top of each other and align it
within point o1 microns and do it and
just can you can understand what we're
talking about you know the difference
between physicist and mechanical
engineers that physics talk about it and
mechanical engineers have to do it
that's first professor lloyd these
things do they have to go you know you
know I was I was at a meeting the other
day and I pointed out to some people
that when we went to the moon in 1969
the computers that we used to go to the
moon were so elementary I mean compared
to the today's pcs in terms of power and
those astronauts literally what I call
that they had the as test you know it
different they really literally had to
fly those things with their feel you
know you can't see very much as you know
and to me it's amazing that we were able
to do that at the time we did it when
you think about it the amount of
computer power we have today compared
what we had in the sixties is just well
no in 1965 was the IBM 360 was invented
so 69 there's not much technology and
the pcs didn't come until about 1981 82
and as you know they were 8-bit machines
and and they were very very slow
Elementary so next one please
this is kind of an actual picture of
that schematic diagram of we used some
robots and and frankly these materials
have to be very light very stiff and
damped very accurate and so we do this
actually believe it or not these
machines to exist in production next one
and they are making wafers every day and
that's what enables the whole
information technology there's another
picture whether wafer is these are eight
inch wafers and we're going to 12 inch
wafers and of course then you can see
handling making a 12 inch wafer and
making a smooth photoresist on it at 10
to 15 angstrom accuracy you can see gets
much more difficult and we are working
very closely by the way with the MIT
because the knowledge today is we don't
have all the knowledge and we really try
to tap on the knowledge the University
so that we can get best technology
available in fact I'll show you some
slides later as to why it's so important
for industry to work with with the
University today whether it's mighty
abducted this because the information is
transferring so fast today that the days
when researchers made something wrote
some papers and 10 15 20 years later it
went into industry by osmosis or
diffusion whatever it is is no longer
valid you really have to get instant
latest technology and as well as the
professor's professors need to get work
with the industry to find out the real
applications and NAMM tells me many
times when it comes visit us these
machines salary things of 10 ideas and
and his pro his students communities
professors because what we do a lot of
times you know whether we're trying to
accomplish something and we don't burst
in a foxhole we don't see some time
what's going on and one professors and
the student comes in he sees all these
things that we're doing wrong and or we
can do better that in other writing
interaction is necessary between
industry and university today another
one please
another picture of the robotics that we
use and another one we use optical
polishing two one three hundredths of a
wave and we used to use old what I call
German opticians because we don't even
make opticians in America anymore with
to really polish these things the
measure is polish but now believe it or
not in California Richmond there's a
company called Tinsley which we
purchased
we devout they developed a basically a
method computer-controlled where they
are measured they are measuring while
they are polishing with the feedback and
we can do spheric as well as aspheric
lenses and this was really done and
that's a bit probably the best place in
the world where we can actually do a
spherical lenses very accurately by
computer-controlled optical polishing
next one place this is a picture about
how when we rotate what I call the wafer
and we put photoresist on it you can see
all the flaws and the pressures and and
that that'll occur when you really want
to make this thing very very very thin
the reason that you have to control
within 10 to 15 angstroms is because if
you don't because every chip is about
maybe nowadays between 1 centimeter
square or 2 centimeters and you have to
make sure that every part of that wafer
has a uniform flow otherwise you don't
get the speed and you don't get what I
call Siddha control critical dimension
control accurately if you don't have the
thickness right and therefore you don't
get good yield and yield is the name of
the game in this business next one
please
well Mechanical Engineers you know we
also has very very much interesting
sensors actuators and of course some of
you are very composing and controlling
as you know controls it about 15 years
ago control was very very very important
now of course it's going more into
biotechnology as well as a lot of
numeric AIT technology but actually
important and all these technologies we
use linearization which is the chemical
mechanical polishing it really is
extremely important today it's a very
dirty process it's really polishing and
then it's grinding but except you have
to do it very accurately because if you
don't do it right you basically eat into
the chips and you have very low yield
it's another mechanical engineering
process go ahead please that that gives
you this picture probably gives you what
we're talking about you know as most
you know once said to me there's 10,000
microns and your hair is about you know
what 300 microns so we do just to get an
idea 1 thousands of it here 0.18 now
it's less than that even for maybe one
three thousand or in here so it's really
very very small dimensions we are
dealing with and we have to measure it
and fabricate it and control it and of
course keep the desktop next one please
this is a vector this electromagnetic
spectrum that gives you an idea but
basically we are working today at
basically the G and H lines are 46
nanometers and the eye line which is
what's used about until about 5 years
ago 3 and 65 nanometers we are using two
forty eight nanometers now and now we're
going to 193 of course next is 157
nanometers that's basic the source of
light next one please
as I said our company is the leading
producer of lithography we really do
deep UV beyond we reach the lower than
4000 shorter than four thousand
angstroms or 400 nanometers which is
visible light and we go we're going with
193 next is 157 and an e UV and these
are all optics until about 2006 or 2008
we were still doing geometric optics
people want to know when the technology
is going to stop we still using the
optics EUV can start considering whether
we're going beyond optics and there's a
lot of discussion now in universities
whether we should go to the next it's
gonna be on human cells or tissue
instead of silicon but right now I think
for the next 10 years we will be using
silicon and optical techniques next one
please
and I think what I talked about is what
mechanical engineers to to me to optical
basically to information technology and
I think I won't spend some time telling
you what information technology has done
to ask the mechanical engineering and it
helps us in product design in
manufacturing and they call mechatronics
I'm sure some of you here
teach mechatronics in your school
from please as you know if if da Vinci
had computers you know and see CAD
systems as you can see that the design
that he he his innovation was not any
worse than with it except didn't have
the tools so the tools that we have
today like the action action Matic
design that we use really really speed
up I really make mechanical engineering
life very easy for understand when I was
designing things we used to make parts
that fit together sometimes we made
mistakes and parts didn't fit that is
simple the holes with the wrong place
today you can actually do on CAD you can
actually simulate it make sure they are
in the right place and before you do it
and equally by the way most of you will
software software has the same
incompatibility is that the hardware
does and most of the time software guys
get away with it just get away with
selling things that are not finished
unfortunately in hardware it can't and
you computer suddenly freezes you put a
new program in a new application program
the damn things don't work so what
happens because there's a software
compatibility with it but so forgotten
admit that it says you know it's a user
problem that's why they charge a 15% a
year to just maintain it but what those
things can be done by action Matic
design it really looked at the actual
Matic design really nothing with a
replacement of a good engineer if you
have a good engineer who really thinks
clearly you know you probably use
actually I design mentally but if you
but actually design makes a good
engineer a great engineer by showing
systematically what you have to do and
what what avoids potential problems and
conflicts next yeah
next one please like I said we have I
mean now we're using pcs we have
computer networks now we are using well
using the internet now for really
sharing data and sharing knowledge
through we used to use a picture picture
tears and other things by the television
didn't work now we have to use the
internet actually you can share data and
online instead of waiting for a long
time so actually botanical engineers now
use that next one please
and I think this is a very interesting
chart and I think this is something that
all of you in the academia really should
really pay attention this is an
important in it shows here that in the 1
megabyte it the red one is in the 1
megabyte see how long it took it took
about almost 186 almost 4 or 5 years for
it to mature to its to its maturity with
the number of units it's on the left on
the abscissa is the on the ordinate is
there no millions of units and on the
abscissa is the years it took four or
five years for it to mature and then it
took almost 10 years to decay but the
next generation
it took fast faster ramp and the next
generation is faster than even yet and
right now we are really doing over 64
mega megabytes going going you know
right now it's dying but look how fast
that grew and now we're going 256
megabit and it's really growing faster
but the message really here is and I
have another chart that will show you
which is that's why I think it's
extremely important for universities and
industry to work together and in the
next chart please
this is a chart that was recently
published I think in Business Week
you can argue with the numbers but
fundamentally it says that it took if
the on the left side on the ordinate you
see the know the percentage of US
population penetrated and the abscissa
is the number of years since the product
invented you can argue whether the the
telephone or the automobile or directory
was invented you can change it by ten
years here and there but the point is it
took almost let's say 50 years 260 years
for the automotive to penetrate 25
percent of the population and if you
look at the Left farthest left chart it
took less than six years or five years
for the Internet to penetrate 25 percent
population and the message really is
that things are moving a lot faster and
I think it's extremely extremely
important for us in industry and
academia to work together and vice versa
because we don't have the knowledge we a
lot of us don't have and you have a lot
of new ideas and new knowledge and I
think we give you a lot of application
capability we give something to sink
your teeth into and I really think
that's extremely important for us to
establish the collaborative effort and
we have here next one please
in manufacturing supply supply lines and
as you know let me just give you an
example that not even in our industry my
brother-in-law is a vice president of a
garment industry you know so what's
relevant about garment industry to our
business depth it used to be
Sears and Walmart and all these guys
they ordered something and they
basically got the clothes and they put
them in a warehouse and they huge they
built huge warehouses they'd still be do
these things into their various stores
and the information and then they they
basically sold them today what happens
is this huge department stores like
Walmart or it Sears or any others
literally go they have thousands of
distributors and suppliers and they tell
them to tag this mother machine whatever
clothes they're making and you know in
the clothing business believe it or not
clothing is just as perishable as
computers I mean if you don't sell
something for the spring that they're
working like right now they are working
on the next fall fashion and if the
fashion doesn't sell it's perishable
that's why you get them to all these
octet stores because and they really so
they have to do they have to get this
machine you have to accept the design
they have to manufacture it they make
them make it to various sizes put them
in to put the tags and sell it direct
send it directly to the store and in the
story of all these new computers now
they even tell you exactly where it came
from and we did every day they look at
how much they are selling and within two
three days
sell that much they take it and they
send it back and already sell it a lot
it automatically reorder it what I'm
saying is even as mundane industry as
the clothing industry the whole
information and the speed of operation
and happening so we in mechanical
engineering we in the manufacturing we
have to do the same thing we really are
really improve our process lines process
systems and the days when you're he
designed a part and he went to the
machine shop to him updated he got it
and he was wrong he got it back again it
doesn't do it anymore you really have to
do things accurately and very very fast
next one please
another area that we connected
engineering reliability you cannot do
things when I came to this industry 15
years ago our machines probably worked
about 150 one week one week 660 some
other hours and the way they looked at
it a machine lasts a week without
anybody touching it they were okay but
when you are going it with lights out
what I call automated factories and you
have 500 steps to make a semiconductor
and you have a lot of machines different
machines complex machines different
processes and you under lights out
factory without people which because
people contaminate the circuit you have
to have reliable machines don't that
have to work and uptime suddenly has to
go into thousands not hundreds of hours
these complex machines have to work
reliably and what better thing to do the
mechanical engineering to really make
these things all these dynamics things
really really reliable all this
probabilistic theory said and you have
to design things properly it's extremely
important he cannot get automation
without reliability as you know the jet
engine I mean if you had an old airplane
engine you know every few hundred hours
you had to really do fix it jet engines
last 12,000 15,000 hours with pigeon
overhauls and you know how many how very
seldom you hear a jet engine fail in
airplane you just take it for granted
today because of mechanical engineers
those are the guys who were teaching at
MIT in nine men I came here
just
the next one please well I think that
all these diagnostic systems internally
to really self correction right now
we're learning machines that instead of
sending all these technicians all over
the world we can actually diagnose them
remotely and start to get the
information and then immediately feed
back to the manufacturing floor so these
are all systems that the new information
is helping mechanical engineers get
systems fast in the old days you have to
bring the part in you have to spend on
Java and analyzing it next one please
but today you have to do it faster and I
think I think there's a professor on too
I'm sure that teach mechatronics the
whole system of working together of
traditional systems and all systems next
one please
in any case in the 70s we had the silver
technologies then we had the idea the
architect knowledge II now I think we
have the entire confluence of all the
other systems and and actually feedback
systems and using the technology to
really get our job better so that's what
you have to really teach next one please
that's a complex chart basically I'm
sure most of you can draw your own chart
or you can use this one when I send you
my son when I send the email to you what
the general field of mechatronics which
is really all a lot of the disciplines
combined into one what we call
mechatronics next one just to give you
one slide on I don't want to slide the
people who do environment engineering I
mean I really feel you can spend a lot
of time deciding about that's the next
field of bioengineering and I really
think I'm very pleased at MIT and their
professors Susie leadership and Neil
Pappalardo chairmanship adopted the
concept of creating your very strong
bioengineering field at MIT because I
really feel that that's the next
basically the horizon for us to conquer
as to how we can get this complex body
that we have you know I always say God
was a very good engineer because every
time you look at
the body the way it works it's amazing
so I think if we understand it and
measure it with a lot of mechanical
engineering principles and use some of
that to really influence it and correct
it we can probably don't have to
practice medicine we can actually do
medicine
so basically next one so so basically is
that a lot of examples of you know we
always think of sport engineering and
other biotechnology as bioengineering
but basically mechanical just pressure
temperature you need floor and all these
things we have to use that's it thank
you you can take that slide out so I
just want to let you let you know that
mechanical engineering is at the heart
of things and I think that the job here
again is to teach some very very basic
principles and teach people how to learn
as they adapt themselves you know I was
like I said I was only a mechanical
engineer at HP that was accepted but now
of course things are a lot different and
they realized that mechanical
engineering has a huge contribution to
right industry okay thank you
[Applause]
no questions thank you